one last thought to leave you on kanye
west
kanye west tweets out yesterday that
he's the new moses
kanye west said i need to see
everybody's contracts at universal and
sony i'm not gonna watch my people be
enslaved
i'm putting my life on the line for my
people the music industry and the nba
are modern day slave ships
i'm the new moses he's catching a lot of
flak for saying this that kanye west is
moses
love that he's right he's right i said
this earlier when kanye was saying he
was going to run for president
i read his platform and i said look it's
obviously eccentric and he's a performer
and an entertainer i said
but at a base philosophical level this
guy
gets politics better than 70
of even elected republicans and
certainly than the entire left
kanye west he's an idiot he's a fool
he's a rube he's a deplorable and
irredeemable he didn't know anything
that guy knows more than a lot of people
what he's talking about here in this
media establishment and more broadly the
liberal establishment is a modern-day
slavery of the mind it is a slavery of
the mind
that seeks but to destroy our
culture vox.com the liberal outlet
is now going after beethoven trying to
destroy beethoven maybe we'll try to get
to that tomorrow
trying to destroy the whole culture that
is a mental slavery that is going to
tear people apart tear our culture apart
and it's being pushed at the highest
levels with the wise and the experts and
the one consolation we have i know i say
often on the show that a conservative
constellation is that reality reasserts
itself in the end
another one is providence providence the
way that
even bad things get turned for good in
this world
and they do it not because of any
cockamamie academic theory they do it
because
god says so darn it and
all those bitter clinging deplorable
irredeemable rube idiots
who believe in crazy concepts like god
you know against the will of all of the
the white lab coats
those people those common foolish people
often turn out to be right i hope you
enjoyed this segment of
the michael knowles show and you should
know on september 28th
the michael knowles show will be moving
from the daily wire youtube channel to
the michael noll show youtube channel
because that just makes sense doesn't
it's right there it's right there
in the name there is a link in the
description below head on over
subscribe to the michael noel show
youtube channel ring the bell
you will never miss another video
[Music]
you